Hugh Jackman's final Wolverine outing
Logan arrived to a ton of critical
acclaim but in addition to being a great
film it also ushers in some huge changes
for the x-men franchise from bidding
farewell to a few of the franchise's
biggest stars - showing us essentially
how the x-men come to an end
Logan is a game changer here's why Logan
marks the end of an era for superhero
films the old x-men movies are over
since debuting on the silver screen in
2000 the original x-men cast has popped
up in pretty much every era of the
franchise ever since they anchored the
original trilogy returned for the future
part of Days of Future past and had
cameos everywhere in between now we have
Jackman's Logan and Patrick Stewart's
Xavier back to wrap it all up here and
that's what this film does it serves as
a coda for that era of the franchise as
20th Century Fox looks to keep the focus
on its younger line of the stars with
the eventual sequel to x-men apocalypse
this is the bookend for the story that
started it all Jackman and Stewart rx
x-men there's one thing that tides
pretty much the entire x-men franchise
together regardless of era and best
Jackman thanks to the fact that
Wolverine doesn't age and apparently
neither does Jackman seriously look at
this guy anyway he's popped up in pretty
much every x-men film except for
Deadpool and even in that movie his face
still put in an appearance at this point
it's almost not an x-men movie without
Wolverine but all that ends with Logan
Jackman said it is my last time it just
felt like it was the right time to do it
so yeah that's pretty clear while the
franchise had found success with younger
actors and new characters like Deadpool
losing Jackman means the future of the
x-men story have never been less clear
along with Jackman the original
Professor Xavier the guy who started the
x-men in the first place is also calling
it quits Stewart is one of the most
recognizable actors in association with
his franchise and he says he's retiring
- James McAvoy has done a solid job of
taking up Stewart's mantle as young
Xavier in the prequel film but for a
certain generation of fans Stewart will
always be Professor X it's the final
Wolverine soul
film The Wolverine spin-off franchise
started out on a rough note with x-men
origins Wolverine which was pretty much
a trainwreck but think got on the right
path with the samurai pin The Wolverine
which helps properly set the stage for
Logan but Logan marks the end of the
Wolverine trilogy that's not to say Fox
won't eventually recast the role at some
point but it's still the end of an era
for Jackman's defining take on the
character it pushes the limits the rave
reviews I'll make one thing clear when
it comes to Logan it's a fantastic movie
and that isn't being graded on a curve
against the adjusted scale of comic book
movies Logan is a brutal beautiful
personal journey that doesn't try to set
world ending stakes this is a small
story that shows the near limitless
potential for what can be done within
the format of a superhero movie Logan is
ambitious in its simplicity weaving in
elements from two decades of film to
tell a story about a handful of people
just trying to do what's right it's
further proof superhero movies can just
be movies and good ones to boot what
comes next
Logan wraps up the old saga of x-men
movie but also sets the stage for
whatever Fox wants to do next is it
another future set story after Logan's a
1990 set film following the younger cast
a new series of solo films no one knows
just yet but thankfully Logan also blows
the doors open in regards to what you
can accomplish and the types of stories
you can tell with the x-men the
possibilities are limitless for Fox to
do some truly creative things with the
franchise we can't wait to see what
comes next thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]